[Musique]
bonjour bonjour monsieur Rio je vous en
prie installez-vous merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous et d'être notre invité
ce matin vous êtes le maire communiste
de greini meilleur maire du monde merci
d'être avec nous on va évidemment
longuement parler de ces annonces
d'Élisabeth borne hier he 4 mois après
les émeutes vous étiez vous à la
Sorbonne pour écouter la première
ministre et plusieurs de ces ministres
avant de rentrer dans le détail des
mesures est-ce que la copie remise hier
au maire par le gouvernement vous
satisfait je suis satisfait du discours
de madame la Première ministre qui dans
un moment où la France est fracturée
souffre de multiples fractures a eu un
discours responsable et sérieux face à
un événement qui a choqué la France
entière euh j'ai trouvver l'unité
nationale et dans cette période c'était
intéressant ensuite il y a un catalogue
je pas dire le catalogue de la doute
mais il y a un catalogue avec des choses
où je me retrouve des choses où je me
retrouve moins et des choses où je me
retrouve pas du tout mais après VO vous
allez nous dire lesquels on va rentrer
dans le détail mais elle a clairement
passé un message de fermeté hier
ellisabeth borne c'était le bon message
à envoyer je n'ai pas entendu que ça
c'est étonnant le monde médiatique parle
beaucoup de ça alors oui bien évidemment
fermeté rétablissement de l'ordre mais
pas que hein moi j'étais à la sbonne
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit pendant 2h3
avec mes collègues euh j'ai entendu
effectivement police j'ai entendu
justice euh j'ai entendu réseaux sociaux
donc voilà on sent un pays qui cherche à
répondre à une nouvelle donne parce que
il y a une nouvelle géographie des
émeutes ce n'est pas la même
géographique les émeutes que nous avons
connu en 2005 et donc on a un pays qui
est un peu stupéfait face à ce qui s'est
passé très rapide dans des villes
moyennes dans des petites villes dans la
ruralité je rappelle que 2 tiers des
émeutes ne se sont pas déroulé dans les
quartiers politique de la ville donc on
a une un gouvernement qui est face à une
situation qui cherche des solutions
ouais c'est ce qu'on rappela Elisabeth
borne et Gérald armanin effectivement la
spécificité de ces émeutes par rapport à
celle de 2005 2010 qui est que des
villes en quartier prioritaire de la
ville n'ont pas été touché alors que des
villes qui n'ont pas ces quartiers ont
été touchées des villes moyennes c'est
surprenant cette géographie entre
guillemets des oui c'est c'est
surprenant c'est le fait nouveau en fait
malheureusement c'est pas le temps émeut
ou violent sur ben c'est des territoires
qui n'ont jamais été percutés par ce
type de phénomène avec bien évidemment
le rôle des réseaux sociaux avec bien
évidemment une extrême
jeunesse qui interroge tout le monde et
donc tout le monde est un peu stupéfait
et on cherche de nouvelles solutions
quand je dis on c'est bien évidemment le
gouvernement de la République et puis
les élus que nous sommes de manière
transpartisan nous étions sur le terrain
nous avons passé des nuits entières
pendant cette périodelà
voilà il a été beaucoup question des
Maes hier évidemment on va parler des
mesures pour qu'on comprenne bien ce qui
vous satisfait ce qui vous satisfait pas
et ce qu'il faut améliorer d'abord sur
la réponse pénale Elisabeth B qui a dit
que c'est parce que la réponse pénale a
été rapide et fermes que nous avons plus
rétablir l'ordre en quelques jours en
juillet elle veut élargir la palette de
sanction pour qu'aucun acte ne reste
impuni et ce dès la première infraction
ça rappelle ce qu'avait dit Emmanuel
Macron en juillet dès la première
connerie il faut une réponse pénale plus
ferme
oui si vous me permettez euh l'acte
majeur pour moi j'ai parlé du discours
de la première ministre d'unité
nationale mais aussi un changement dans
ce
quinena c'est-à-dire que ce gouvernement
et le président de la République
considèrent que les maires sont un peu
la solution dans ce pays lorsqu'il nous
a reçu au mois de juillet le président
de la République a fait son moupa devant
les maires juste après les émeutes en
disant je me suis trompé vous êtes une
partie de la solution que la première
ministre reçoive 500 m à la Sorbonne ou
ailleurs pour nous dire vous faites
partie de la solution il y a un
changement dans ce quinquena un retour à
l'uminité le corps intermédiaire que
nous sommes après le covid après les
émeutes est quelque chose d'important
donc je voulais c'est important pour
dire ça au-udelà de vous faites partie
de la solution il y a il y a eu aussi
vous allez être mise à contribution
entre guillemets en tout cas vous allez
être plus impliqué on va y revenir mais
juste sur la réponse pénale oui bien
évidemment qu'il faut de la sécurité les
Français attendent de la sécurité après
ils attendent un triyptique prévention
sécurité et cohésion sociale ce matin se
tient à Chantou les viges le comité
interministériel des ville que nous
attendons depuis un an un an et demi
pour laquelle nous travaillons avec les
services de la première ministre et j'y
vais d'ailleurs tout à l'heure chez ma
collègue Catherine
arénou je trouve que sur le volet
prévention on aurait pu faire un peu
mieux parce qu'on fait pas que de la
sécurité avec la sécurité la grande
différence entre 2005 et 2013 et 2023
pardon c'est objectivement une
croissance exponentiel des dépenses
publiques en matière de
sécurité les polices municipales ont
explosé ont poussé comme des champignons
je vous parle même pas de la vidéo
protection on a cru que la vidéo
protection était l'alpha et l'oméga des
politiques de sécurité ou la baguette
magique donc entre 2005 et 2023 c'est
pas le cas pour vous moi je a dans ma
ville c'est un outil il faut de l'humain
aussi c'estàd qu'il faut des hommes et
des femmes sur le terrain de proximité
qui puissent faire le leur job et puis
on est suffisamment pardon je fais une
parenthèse sur la la vidéo protection
parce que Géral armanin il rappelait
hier qu'il y a une enveloppe qui avait
été attribuée au maire de 20 millions et
que seul 2,5 millions de ces crédits
avaient été consommés il lance
d'ailleurs un appel au mare ça veut dire
que les mares s'en saisissent pas assez
bah je sais pas le sentiment que j'ai
franchement euh j'ai le sentiment que
les villes
s'équipent ces 10 dernières années de
manière de manière importante elles ont
on a dépassé un débat idé lique pour ou
contre c'est un outil euh de sécurité de
tranquillité publique très clairement
mais pas le seul mais évidemment pas le
seul il faut il faut de l'humain il faut
vous saz la sécurité c'est de la
coproduction pendant les émeutes Madame
La La La La Première ministre a parlé
beaucoup des forces de police d'ailleurs
je trouve qu'ils ont un peu oublié les
pompiers qui ont joué un rôle
extrêmement important ma collègue maire
de Mitri mais Charlotte Blando
Farid a pris la parole et a dit mais les
citoyens ont été extrêmement présents h
effectivement des pères de famille des
mères de famille le tissu associatif
était présent pendant ces pendant ces
momentsl pour calmer pour ne pas que
tout cela s'enflamme encore plus les
élus locaux donc voilà la sécurité c'est
une coproduction il y a les citoyens je
parle pas de je pas de milice les
polices municipales qui ont joué
évidemment un rôle et la police
nationale qui on va se le dire parfois
étéit légèrement débordée parce que pas
assez de parce
que parce que beaucoup de soudaineté
dans tous les sens et il y a eu la
première nuit ou la deuxième quelques
endroits qui voilà où ça a été difficile
pour pour maintenir l'ordre mais il
fallait le maintenir maintenant on doit
réparer les les PL encore une fois
prévention sécurité cohésion sociale
alors on va parler de la police
municipale puisque vous en parliez on
reviendra à la réponse judiciaire un peu
plus tard mais Gérald harmanin
ellisabeth borne ont dit hier qu'il
voulaiit donner la possibilité au police
municipale de faire certains actes de
police judiciaire est-ce que c'est une
bonne chose pour vous non pourqu
clairement non parce qu'en fait derrière
ça se cache l'idée selon laquelle porté
par des élus locaux hein
euh il y a un côté police àaméricaine et
shérif derrière tout ça et il y a il va
y avoir si on met le doigt là-dedans une
inégalité en matière de sécurité de
tranquillité publique en clair les
villes financièrement bien doté qui vont
pouvoir se payer une police de dingue
m'entendez une police de dingue et puis
celles qui ont peu ou pas de moyens qui
ne vont pas pouvoir suivre le rythme
donc la question c'est que notre police
nationale qui est c'est un pouvoir
régalien puisse réinvestir là où il y a
moins de police et fondamentalement où
est-ce qu'il y a moins de police on le
sait tous dans les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville et puis dans un
certain nombre de secteurs ou de villes
moyennes donc il y a besoin de plus de
police mais aussi de mieux de police
mais Géral d'manin hier il a parlé de la
frustration de certains maires qui ont
une police municipale qui est de plus en
plus équipée de plus en plus formé et
qui n'a pas suffisamment de pouvoirs ce
qui sapent l'autorité de la police mais
aussi l'autorité du maire vous partagez
pas ce constat je je ne le partage pas
il y a un débat je ne partage pas ça je
pense qu'on met le doigt dans dans une
fuite en avant qui qui est pas terrible
pour notre pays donc quand il annonce
parce que il veut faire évoluer les
choses et il parle d'un dispositif
volontaire où les maires entreront
volontairement pour agrandir les
pouvoirs de la police municipale vous
n'y rentrerez pas dans ce dispositif
écoutez la première ministre a annoncé
plein de pistes de travail avec des
commissions des projets de loi donc on
va rentrer dans le détail ça vaut aussi
pour la responsabilité des parents il y
a des choses au bout d'un moment on va
être bloqué monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur a été clair aussi hein avec
monsieur le garde des saau il y a un
truc qui s'appelle le Conseil
constitutionnel je rappelle que la
judiciarisation de la police municipale
a fait déjà l'objet d'un assaut qui a
été retoqué par le Conseil
constitutionnel moi je pense qu'il faut
qu'on tienne bon d' sa volonté de
rechercher une solution avec le et
fameux dispositument la coordination
police municipale police nationale est
extrêmement
importante vous avez peur clairement
philiip Rio vous avez peur que sur cette
question l'État le gouvernement cherche
à se décharger sur les mes c'est ça oui
très
clairement c'estàdire il veut pas sous
couvert de vouloir vous renforcer de
vous donner plus d'autorité il cherche à
se décharger sur vous ben ça va être ça
oui oui ça va être ça très clairement
d'où votre inquiétude sur ce dispositif
on va revenir à la réponse pénale vous
en avez un peu parlé euh Elisabeth B
veut responsabiliser les parents elle
veut des stages euh de responsabilité
parental ou des peines de travaux
d'intérêt général pour les parents qui
se soustrai à leur devoir éducatif
est-ce que vous y êtes favorable à ça
euh
euh sur des questions un peu un peu
directes moi j'ai entendu deux choses
hier
il y avait d en même temps et la
responsabilité et en même temps le
soutien aux familles si vous me
permettez de de petites secondes sur de
quoi on parle ce qui est ciblé dans les
auteurs des des délits qui ont été
commis euh et pointer du doigt les
familles
monoparentales famille monoparental
c'est une famille sur 5 en France quatre
familles monoparentales sur 10 V sous le
seuil de pauvreté et on considère que
les parents ne tiennent pas assez leurs
enfants parents un métier très dur même
qu'on est a le papa et la maman à la
maison hein
euh donc des stages très concrètement ça
va poser un certain nombre de de
difficultés lorsque dans une famille
j'en connais beaucoup et tout le monde
en connaît il y a trois enfants avec
deux qui sont dans des parcours de
réussite exemplaires et un qui a fait
des mauvaises rencontres qui a fait le
pas de côté euh on va demander aux
parents de de faire un stage parce qu'il
y en a un sur trois qui est parti en
vrille compliqué tout cela donc euh euh
voilà et en même temps ces familles
monoparentales dont je parlais euh 30 %
des familles monoparentales n'ont pas
accès à leurs droits et c'était l'autre
volet qui a été développé développé par
madame la ministre des Solidarités que
je trouve moi très intéressant et je
trouve que dans ma ville une stratégie
de de lutte contre la pauvreté on
travaille sur ces questions en fait les
familles monoparentales euh 85 % des
familles monoparentales c'est une femme
qui assure euh la gestion de la famille
n'ont pas accès à leurs droits donc en
clair on est au cœur de la pauvreté
euh des familles qui sont compl parental
Elizabeth borne elle elle a dit hier
très clairement les deux parents doivent
assumer les responsabilités pas
uniquement le le père ou la mère voilà
chez le elle a pas dit comme ça mais en
tout cas elle dit c'est pas uniquement
le parent chez lequel vit l'enfant il
faut que les deux parents assument leur
responsabilité non je pense qu'il faut
il faut regarder ça de de près la
question de l'autorité parentale bien
évidemment se pose comme l'autorité de
l'État comme l'autorité générale à
l'école on a voilà on a on a un pays je
parlais de multiples fractures ça en est
une mais encore une fois pas l'alpha et
l'oméga mais il faut faut faut
travailler cette question c'est sûr il a
été aussi évoqué la question des drogues
de la drogue de la lutte contre le
trafic de drogue là aussi ellisabeth
borne veut aller encore plus loin le
gouvernement doit en faire plus sur ce
sujet ou oui très clairement il a été
annoncé une nouvelle stratégie de lutte
contre la drogue comme une stratégie
d'ailleurs une nouvelle stratégie de la
prévention de la délinquence donc voilà
il y a plein de chantiers ont été
ouverts hier euh oui sur la drogue très
clairement euh il faut
euh il faut arrêter le monde de
bisounours dans lequel nous sommes alors
j'entends bien que il faut pénaliser les
consommateurs euh j'attends aussi qu'il
y ait des gros coups de filet et
d'énormes coups de filet pour les gros
trafiquants en fait parce que dans nos
quartiers ù ailleurs on souffre de la
des superettes qui sont dans nos caches
d'escalier or si les superetes ne sont
plus fourni par les grossistes euh donc
un travail de douane d'enquête de
démantelllement et puis il faut créer un
autre système parce que saz le problème
de la drogue c'est que ça a créé c'est
une économie parallèle mais c'est aussi
une vie parallèle et effectivement on a
une jeunesse qui a mis doigts de pied
là-dedans et qui est prisonnier d'un
système où je rappelle hein il y a des
enfants de 12 13 ans qui travaille pour
les trafics il y a du travail d'enfant
dans ces trafics qui rapportent
énormément d'argent c'est dévastateur
dévastateur difficile de rattraper après
on a on y arrive parfois et ça
effectivement c'est c'est mortifère pour
notre nation certains notamment chez les
républicains veulent qu'on pointe aussi
la responsabilité du consommateur qui
alimente ce trafic est-ce qu'il faut
pointer cette responsabilité ou pourrait
le faire pour l'alcool ou cigarettes
donc c'est pas une bonne idée
c'estes limite vous parlez de la
stratégie de prévention de la
délinquence alors là aussi il a été
question des maires he puisque Gérald
haranin a dit il faut il faut pas que le
maire soit à côté il faut que le maire
soit au cœur deux il faut qu'on
retravaille un dispositif pour mettre le
maire au cœur d'eux de quelle manière
selon vous aujourd'hui la stratégie dans
laquelle nous étions était partenariale
mais un peu trop partenarial trop de
partenariat tue le partenariat euh on
était 20 300 autour de la table et et
chacun dans un jeu d'acteur un peu
étrange disait bah tout ce qu'il faisait
c'était bien en fait tout ce qu'on fait
n'est pas toujours bien faut se le dire
y compris nous les maires on fait des
erreurs on se plante ça nous arrive
aussi
euh je pense qu'il faut resserrer police
justice on a d'autres acteursin je pense
aux transporteurs je pense aux bailleurs
sociaux le rôle des gardiens euh il y a
il y a tout ce monde là qui doit être
remis donc il y a en fait on arrive à
bout de souff d'un système d'une
stratégie qui était un peu ancienne qui
a été efficace à un moment et puis qui
s'estessfflé comme souvent dans les
politiques publiques lorsqu'on
rechallenge pas tout ça ben voilà là
c'est le bon moment non moi je trouve
que c'est il faut il faut le refaire en
tout cas on a besoin de ces outils là
nous localement les maires c'est des
artisans on a besoin d'outils pour
travailler avec les acteurs locaux donc
il faut il faut redynamiser tout ça
alors hier on avait les réponses
régaliennes du gouvernement aujourd'hui
vous nous le disiez il y a ce comité
interministériel des villes avec des
réponses plus larges hein qui sont
attendu notamment sur l'emploi sur
logement sur le logement
pardon c'est un comité ministériel qui a
été mains de fois reporté qu'est-ce que
vous en attendez
euh effectivement c'est commencé à
devenir un peu
l'arlaisienne d'abord nous on y a
beaucoup travaillé comme on a l'habitude
de faire depuis l'appel de greini le
rapport borlau le CIV de greini qui
s'est tenu en janvier 2021 avec sous la
houlette de de Jean
Castex les sén ché depuis la la France
s'est
crispée moi on regarde l'ensemble des
collègues vous savez on est une petite
association de M de ville et banlieu
présidée par Gill Leprou ma d'allonene
dans la banlieu du man on fêtaé nos 40
ans la semaine
dernière la France s'est crispée on sent
du séparatisme d'en bas mais aussi d'en
haut on sent que les élites françaises
n'ont plus envie d'intervenir là la
politique de la ville c'est pas une
politique pour les quartiers c'est une
politique pour les nations et donc on
attend de la première ministre un
discours qui embarque la nation entière
vous savez dans nos quartiers populaire
il y a la jeunesse soit on fait 100 et
c'est la catastrophe soit on fait avec
et on en tire le meilleur et nous on
veut en tirer le meilleur donc on attend
un discours de la première ministre une
ambition une méthode une feuille de
route se voir tous les 6 mois pour faire
une évaluation parce qu'une politique
publ sans évaluation c'est de la flute
enchantée je le dis vraiment de cette
manière-là donc on a besoin de cela on
croit en ça il y a pas de baguette
magique voilà moi je tiens à faire
passer un message aujourd'hui il y a pas
de baguette magique c'est pas parce
qu'on fait plus de sport qu'on y
arrivera c'est pas parce qu'on fait plus
de culture qu'on y arrivera c'est pas
parce qu'on fait plus de sécurité plus
de logement c'est quand on fait tout ça
en même temps l'ession ouais mais on a
l'impression Philippe Rio depuis des
années il y en a eu des mesures il y en
a eu des plans il y en a eu des
financements qu'est-ce qui ne marche pas
oui vous savez les crises on a il faut
qu'on comprenne en France que les crise
vont plus vite que les politiques
publiques qui doivent les réparer et
donc quand on nanticipe pas quand on est
en retard on court toujours après le
train et force c'est de constater que
depuis par exemple le rapport borlot en
6 ans qu'est-ce qui s'est passé mais la
situation s dégradé il y a eu un truc
qui s'appelle le covid-19 il y a eu un
truc qui s'appelle l'inflation
aujourd'hui il y a un conflit
international qui interroge et qui
crisse tout le monde il y a eu aussi des
attentats il y en a eu un nouveau il y a
un professeur qui est mort qui a été
assassiné et donc tout ça on a une
France qui est extrêmement crispée
parliez aussi de lo immigration qui va
réinterroger tout ça donc faire
fraternité c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué donc dire
qu'on a toujours fait mais en fait on a
toujours fait dans tous les domaines il
y a toujours un plan sur l'armée il y a
toujours un plan sur la sécurité sociale
il y a toujours un plan sur tout donc
oui il y a besoin constamment de se
réinterrogé naturelard il est en retard
aujourd'hui le gouvernement il est pas
en avance il est pas en avance il a pris
du
retard donc encore une fois nous voilà
nous on est là on a tendu la main on a
fait des propositions il y a des choses
qui vont être retenues ce matin mon
petit doigt me l'a dit ditnous il y a
des choses qui vont pas être retenues
euh euh et puis nous on va continuer à
travailler qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'il soit retenu et non on avait une
vieille demande sur une mesure qui avait
été initiée du rapport borlau qui avait
qui avait rapport qui avait été mis à la
poubelle mais un certain nombre de
choses avaient été reprises on avait
cassé une dynamique c'est ça quand je
parle d'ambition de la nation je
rappelle que le plan borlot il y avait
les syndicats qui étaient là le patronat
qui disait allez on y va tous ensemble
voilà faire nation ensemble d'ailleurs
c'est le titre de notre appel de Lyon de
la semaine de la semaine dernière euh je
pense qu'il va y avoir des avancées sur
le logement je pense notamment aux
copropriétés dégradées ça explose
partout en France partout partout
partout il y a des morts dans nos
copropriétés parce que il y a pas
d'entretien parce que ça se dégrade une
vitesse grandv il y a des marchands de
sommeil il y a de la fraude immobilière
donc là on va voir enfin d'autres outils
je pense au cité éducatif pardon c'est
ça dont je voulais parler qui vont être
déployés sur tout le pays là où avec à
Chantelou grenny VO envelin on avait
initié expérimenter bah cette
expérimentation et c'est un peu nouveau
c'est par le bas c'est pas des
politiques descendantes vous savez des
fois il y a derniers kilomètres qui est
difficile là nous on a créé quelque
chose qui a été repris et nous sommes
assez contents
euh sur le sport il y a des choses qui
avancent sur la culture donc voilà il y
a plein de petites choses une stratégie
des petits pas parce que c'est ça dont
il nous faut ou vous êtes plutôt
optimiste aujourd'hui ou est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet est-ce que les émeutes
qu'on a connu au début de l'été elles
peuvent revenir est-ce que la situation
peut de nouveau se redégrader la
situation est dégradée on a besoin de
retrouver du sens on a besoin de trouver
retrouver de la fraternité et nous on a
besoin de d'outils dans la boîte à outil
pour faire avec les acteurs locaux avec
les
associations la doctrine policière et
c'est quelque chose que je n'ai pas
apprécié hier n'a pas été revisité parce
que Naël ça peut exister demain
matin la question de l'abrogation de la
loi 2017 ou d'une igpn indépendante ça
n'a pas été touché c'est je crois
l'angle mort terrible et donc demain naë
qui Galin il a dit c'était pas du
maintien de l'ordre que la police a dû
faire c'est du établissement de l'ordre
public oui mais demain Naël ça peut on
est à l'abri de rien ce qui a mis le feu
aux poudre on dit toujours nous qu'on
vit sur une poudrière à la moindre
étacelle ça pète donc ça ça n'a pas été
résolu ça n'a pas été abordé je pense
que c'est un manque euh
important pour c'est c'est pas compliqué
de faire une igpn indépendante ça coûte
pas d'argent c'est gratuit est-ce que
l'étincelle dont dont vous parlez elle
peut venir de ce qui se passe
actuellement au prochoriant hier on a
appris qu'il y a 719 incidents
antisémites qui ont été recensés depuis
le 7 octobre 389 interpellations est-ce
que vous êtes inquiet des conséquences
de ce conflit aujourd'hui dans notre
pays bien
sûr bien sûr je le suis et je peux vous
dire que tous les maires le sont parce
que on a des signaux qui inquièteent
c'est tendu ça interroge c'est terrible
ce qui se passe à Gaza c'est terrible
qui s'est passé en Israël le 7 octobre
c'est terrible et donc bien évidemment
que ça raisonne ce conflit là raisonne
dans un pays où la communauté juive est
importante dans la dans la commun dans
un pays où la communauté musulmane est
extrêmement importante dans la position
historique et diplomatique qu'a pris la
France une voix singulière qu'on a perdu
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est important
ce ce qui se passe et j'en ai parlé tout
à l'heure dans mes propos dans ces
crispation française donc vous redoutez
cette importation du conflit et les
conséquen ça pourrait avoir et et on
voit bien des forces naséabondes se
mettent en mouvement on voit de la
propagande des deux côtés
d'ailleurs se mettre en mouvement pour
attiser les haines et donc nous on doit
maintenir la paix justement un dernier
mot là-dessus vous êtes mère vous êtes
en première ligne évidemment dans quel
état d'esprit êtes-vous aujourd'hui dans
quel état d'esprit sont les mères est-ce
qu'il y a une forme de découragement oui
il faut regarder le nombre de démissions
de mè et du locau qui a explosé sous ce
mandat
euh j'en parlais hier on est tous
fatigués
rincés après on croit dans ce qu'on fait
donc on peut mettre genoux à terre
parfois et puis repartir parce que il y
a des gens voilà on a onvu des moments
dur mais on a aussi un entourage on a
des équipes qui qui sont là et puis euh
on aime notre pays on aime nos villes on
aime les gens et vous avez envie de
continuer vous serez encore là en 2026
ça c'est autre affaire mais oui oui il y
a mais ce découragement est-ce qu'il va
jusqu'à l'envie de tout lâcher ben
écoutez on est dans un moment où
beaucoup beaucoup plus qu'avant des
maires ont lâché donc bien évidemment
que c'est dans la tête de tout le monde
et bien évidemment quand on voit un
maire qui lâche on se pose des questions
euh mais on est solidaire entre nous je
peux vous assurer hier on voilà on a
envie de repartir c'est pour ça que le
moment d'hier et et le moment de ce
matin est important et voilà l'ambition
et j'ai insisté sur le fait que enfin ce
gouvernement et le président de la
République ne nous considère pas comme
des comme des boulets pour la société
mais on fait notre part nous on est des
gens nous sommes des gens sincères on a
envie de s'engager c'est un engagement
encore une fois
sincère pour la nation pour nos
concitoyens et on fait partie de la
solution donc voilà maintenant on a un
sujet qui est le pouvoir d'agir des
maires au-delà du
statutler ça fait partie des sujets dans
cettej on aura l'occasion d'en parler et
il en sera question lors du congrès des
mer qu'on suivra évidemment avec
attention et on recevra peut-être à
cette occasion un nouveau merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin merci
on passe tout de suite au club des
territoires